chapeau à voilette et Gan couleur crème
ce n'est pas la reine d'Angleterre
simplement une fan de la souveraine qui
repère les lieux trois heures avant la
Royal visite on s'active partout dans
Blois c'est le grand nettoyage les
tireurs d'élite prennent leur position
les amateurs de clichés sont en place ça
y est
la salle du trône pardon des mariages
est enfin prête sa Majesté peut arriver
pour calmer les deux heures et demie
encore à attendre les adorateurs
d'Elizabeth en viennent très vite à
parler des déboires familiaux de leur
idole et je regarde à chaque fois que je
peux la voir quand il y a dire vu ou
qu'elle est dessus je la lis parce que
c'est très intéressant moi je trouve
bien sûr elle a des déboires avec ses
enfants ça qui en a pas
son fils à Booba arrivé à ce qu'il soit
moi ça s'est malheureux oui c'est ça que
je connais le plus vous trouvez que
Charles ivorien
mais il vaut pas ça mais
enfin à mon avis je le connais pas assez
modestement je vais me faire être pas
les donner un conseil chaque famille
fait ce qui peut avec sa propre famille
en tant que mère de famille je sais ce
que c'est et je crois que chaque moment
a beaucoup de responsabilités qu'elle
soit reine ou qu'elle soit simple
roturière
distribution gratuite de fanions
français britannique la mairie de Blois
a pensé à tout les enfants eux
s'interrogent question du jour quel âge
donner à Elisabeth
75 ans
elle y ressemble à 75 ans moi je dirais
plus mais enfin
80 ans la reine d'Angleterre
quel âge il a une séance 66 il a
François Mitterrand il y a 76 ans alors
on peut continuer elle est plus vieille
[Musique]
un peu plus vieille oui je trouve
garde à cheval la République c'est
quelquefois se fait Royal jusque dans
les moindres détails
[Applaudissements]
un écho décrit le spectacle peut
commencer
roquebrise perle de rose rose pâle
également son manteau chaussures et sacs
à main couleur cendre de bois chapeau à
sorti à l'ensemble Elizabeth II donne
encore une fois une démonstration
vivante du dur métier de Rennes
admirez la démarche l'expérience le
professionnalisme pour être capable de
monter sans encombre dans une berline SM
Citroën décapotable
[Applaudissements]
toujours impeccable pas un signe d’ennui
devant ses visites interminables
sourires de rigueur et petit gestes de
la main Jack Lang dans la décapotable
jubiles il se souvient peut-être de sa
première initiale j comme Jeff cave
comme à votre habitude madame vous fût
tout simplement royal en ces lieux
autrefois habité par nos souverains
Elisabeth II et son escort plièrent
bagage en fin d'après-midi restera
l'image magique d'une reine en voyage
[Musique]